I'm tired. Should we go back to our rooms
? We don't know
what will happen to us when we get back, so we'll be together at night anyway. You
look good in this outfit, Senpai.
Why don't you wear it as pajamas? It'll be hard to sleep, right?  Do you
know that everyone had their own plans for murder? No, I
just used my own information and speculation to sway them into talking. If it's a fact that you wouldn't expect, Mr. Chairman,
then it's
necessary to make it public.  I'm sure the chairman, who is an adult,
would be surprised if he knew about this.If you
give a strange problem,
strange things will happen.Well,
I'll tell you about that today.Also, as I
said earlier.  If I don't make it public,
everyone will be distracted by unnecessary thoughts,
and it
will be easier to lead to the appropriate fake solution that I have prepared, so I
can't wait for those people to come up with their own solutions.  It's
easier to do that, so I give them a few keys to help them visualize the solution I've prepared.
If I give them a little more information about the victim's personality and the situation at the time, they might realize it without me having to do it.  Ms.
Lyon is the most expensive one. If she's the one, I
might be able to find the answer I want tonight.